حسنًا ، هذه بعض من أسوأ الاشتباكات
التي شهدتها العاصمة الليبية في العامين الماضيين على الأقل
، وهناك مخاوف حقيقية من
أن هذا قد
يعيد البلاد إلى حالة من الصراع المستمر.
المواجهة السياسية الطويلة بين فصيلين متنافسين
في العاصمة طرابلس لديك
حكومة الوحدة الوطنية غير المدعومة والمعترف بها دوليًا
بقيادة رئيس الوزراء عبد الله بابير
وفي الشرق لديك إدارة منافسة
عينت رئيس وزرائها بشكل أساسي فاتح
بشار الآن.  كانت التوترات بين هذين
الفصيلين محتدمة منذ أشهر
الآن في بشار مايو ،
وشنت القوات المتحالفة معه محاولة فاشلة
للسيطرة على طرابلس ،
وخلال الأسابيع القليلة الماضية رأينا القوات الشرقية
تحشد حول العاصمة ولكن
في نهاية الأسبوع تلك التوترات  وصلت بالفعل
إلى ذروتها مع القوات المتحالفة مع البجاج
مرة أخرى في محاولة للسيطرة
على منطقة في طرابلس.  قم بتطويق
العاصمة من عدة اتجاهات باستخدام
نيران الأسلحة الصغيرة والمدافع الرشاشة الثقيلة
وحتى قذائف الهاون في المناطق الوسطى حول
المدينة ،
ولكن في حين أن هناك موافقة حقيقية ، فإن هذا
قد يدفع البلاد إلى مزيد من
الاضطرابات السياسية ، كان لهذه الاشتباكات
الأخيرة بالفعل
عواقب وخيمة على ما لا يقل عن 30 شخصًا.
قتلى وجرح أكثر من 150 شخصًا
في القتال وفقًا لوزارة الصحة
، وقد دعت الأمم المتحدة
إلى وقف فوري للعنف
والعودة إلى الحوار السياسي ، لكننا سمعنا أيضًا
من زعيم
جنو عبد الله مدبابر يتحدث مساء السبت إلى
مقاتليه المتحالفين.  في العاصمة
أثنى عليهم في
كلماته للدفاع عن المدينة وقدم
احترامه لمن فقدوا
أرواحهم مؤكدًا أن جنو لا يزال
ملتزمًا بالانتخابات الديمقراطية ، لكنه
أصدر أيضًا تحذيرًا صارخًا
لأعضاء المعارضة قائلاً إن الوقت قد حان للتدخل
السياسي.  لقد ولت الانقلابات منذ فترة طويلة وتحذر أيضًا من
أن أي جهات فاعلة تتطلع إلى
السيطرة على البلاد من قبل الأمم المتحدة
الوسائل الديمقراطية ستلتقي بمقاتليه في
الميدان ندير بشير في لندن